[Música]
cuando Nicolás bourbaki solicitó entrar
a la sociedad americana de matemáticas
en los años 50 ya era uno de los
matemáticos más influyentes de su época
había publicado artículos en revistas
internacionales y sus libros eran
lectura obligatoria aún así su solicitud
fue firmemente rechazada por una
sencilla razón Nicolás bourbaki no
existía
dos décadas antes las matemáticas
estaban patas arriba muchos matemáticos
de prestigio murieron en la Primera
Guerra Mundial y el campo de las
Matemáticas se fragmentó
cada rama usaba una metodología
diferente y la falta de un lenguaje
matemático común dificultaba la
divulgación y la expansión de sus
trabajos
[Música]
en 1934 un grupo de matemáticos
franceses se cansó cuando estudiaban en
la prestigiosa ekol normal superior les
pareció que el libro de la clase de
cálculo estaba tan desarticulado que
decidieron escribir uno nuevo y mejorado
El pequeño grupo no tardó en ampliarse y
conforme crecía el proyecto también lo
hacía su ambición el resultado fue el El
Limón de magmatic un tratado con el que
buscaban crear un marco lógico que
unificar a las distintas ramas de las
Matemáticas el texto comenzaba con un
conjunto de axiomas simples leyes e
hipótesis que usaron para construir el
argumento después los autores
desarrollaron teoremas cada vez más
complejos que correspondían con trabajos
realizados en todo el campo de las
Matemáticas pero para revelar realmente
una base común el grupo debía
identificar reglas coherentes que se
pudieran aplicar en multitud de
problemas
para conseguirlo redefinieron claramente
algunos de los objetos matemáticos más
importantes entre los que se incluye la
función
es razonable ver a las funciones como
máquinas que aceptan entradas y producen
salidas pero si las viéramos como un
puente entre dos grupos podríamos
empezar a afirmar sus relaciones lógicas
por ejemplo piense en un grupo de
números y otro de letras podríamos
definir una función en la que cada
entrada numérica correspondiera con una
misma salida alfabética aunque esto no
establecería una relación interesante
una alternativa sería definir una
función en la que cada número se
correspondiera con una letra diferente
esta segunda función establece una
relación lógica en la que al procesar
una entrada se genera el resultado
correspondiente al elemento de salida
asociado el grupo comenzó a definir
funciones Según como asociaban elementos
entre dominios si la salida de la
función provenía de una única entrada la
denominaban inyectiva si todas las
salidas podían asociarse a al menos una
entrada era una función sobreyectiva y
en las funciones biyectivas cada
elemento tenía una correspondencia
perfecta uno a uno esto permitía a los
matemáticos establecer una lógica que
pudiera ser traducida entre los dominios
de las funciones de manera bidireccional
su enfoque sistemático a principios
abstractos contrastaba con la creencia
de que las matemáticas eran una ciencia
intuitiva y una sobredependencia en la
lógica limitada a la creatividad pero
esta banda de eruditos Rebeldes ignoró
la sabiduría convencional estaban
revolucionando el campo de las
matemáticas y querían poner la guinda al
pastel con su mayor hazaña hasta el
momento decidieron publicar
y todos sus siguientes trabajos bajo un
seudónimo colectivo Nicolás bour baki en
las dos siguientes décadas sus
publicaciones se convirtieron en
estándares de referencia y los miembros
del grupo Se tomaron la broma tan en
serio como su trabajo
el matemático imaginario afirmaba ser un
genio Ruso y ermitaño que solo se
reuniría con sus selectos colaboradores
enviaban telegramas en nombre de
bourbaki anunciaron la boda de su hija e
insultaban a cualquiera que dudara de su
existencia En 1968 cuando ya no podían
seguir con El engaño el grupo acabó con
la broma de la única manera posible
imprimiéndolo vituario de bourbaki
plagado de doble sentidos matemáticos a
pesar de su supuesta muerte el grupo con
el nombre de bourbaki aún existe hoy en
día y aunque no esté asociado a ningún
descubrimiento importante la influencia
de llega hasta la investigación actual y
la importancia moderna de las pruebas
formales le debe mucho a su rigurosa
metodología Nicolás bourbaki pudo ser
imaginario pero su legado es muy real
ahora que ha descubierto el misterio de
Nicolás bourbaki Qué le parece si
pasamos a otro que dice este libro si no
puede resolverlo no se preocupe Tampoco
puede nadie más descubra una de las
obras más crípticas de la historia con
este video